hey guys Ryan right here I'm gonna be
watching the second trailer for The Maze
Runner a lot of people are really
excited about this it's about a mouse
collaborative comedy that's what that
was
now I the people love the book the first
trailer kind of looked like Hunger Games
sort of but a lot of people kept telling
me that it's like totally different I
haven't read the book I don't really
care to take time out of my life to read
the book but I will definitely watch
this movie that's way easier than
reading book we go time to run through
the maze you tell me anything about
yourself who you are where you came from
you tell me a name
[Music]
[Music]
there I think it's how we find out what
we're really up against
Devers pictures how's that this is the
first real closure found
who knows with this my readers
to go
everything started changing the moment
you showed up we get out now what we die
trying
you don't get it
[Music]
[Music]
that movie looks really cool I like the
lead actor I don't recall what else I
might have seen him in before but I'm
really liking him he's got that
Hollywood charm the actress though that
the one girl in this movie she doesn't
look too believable to me just a few
lines I heard her say I was like it
sounds like she's acting another side
note if this was like realistic at all
let's face it all those guys with
gangbanger sounds [ __ ] up but that's
just the truth and it probably was her
consent if I was a girl you know I was
surrounded by a bunch of guys totally
looking game being me I do
I like the plot a lot you know I like
the rhyme I I do like the premise it's
very unique it's interesting it's called
the Maze Runner and there's so much
mystery about all this stuff going on I
like movies like that where you kind of
have to figure out what's going on along
the way and you have to you know put
clues together the movie is a maze of
its own like this could have been a
really simple movie where it's just
about them going through the [ __ ]
maze but instead of that they're really
providing like amazing the mind as well
and it doesn't feel like some stupid
young adult novel movie it actually
feels like this could be a great film
for all I know actually so I I'm
genuinely looking forward to watching
this film anyway guys thanks for talking
that trailer was out if you're new to
the channel you can subscribe right here
that would be very much appreciated a
little bit of a maze to drag that mouse
to the subscribe button isn't it you
know or if you're watching this on like
an iPhone or something there supposed to
be a subscribe button here but you
bastards turn your annotations off I
want to get some shout outs here super
awesome boy Alex hey Rainn
I came to say great reaction and video
comedy and have you give me a shout-out
it's okay just I wanted to make sure and
keep making awesome videos super awesome
boy Alex I don't believe I
you a shout out my friend might have
skipped to you by accident that happens
when there's re-request especially but
super awesome boy Alex you're okay I
don't know you so I can't say you're
super awesome but I'm sure you're okay
Dre decent there's decent kindness and
everybody even in the bad guys there's
always a kind of kindness for all I know
you could be a bad guy be a serial
killer for all I know you could be
hacking up a body as I speak right now
thrown in your trunk
driving to the river depositing the body
into the ocean you know for all I know
that could be you and maybe in the
circles you run in that is super awesome
Alex but you know awesomeness is really
dependent on one's own definition so
yeah
prove to me that you're awesome Scott
Dolan hi Ryan so it is my birthday today
is there any chance I could get a
shout-out it was his birthday by the
time this video is up it was two days
ago I believe you my friend have a happy
[ __ ] birthday don't know how old
you're turning but here's what I can say
if you have a girlfriend
she has no excuse for not blowing you
[ __ ] better blow you so get your dick
sucked in even if you don't have a
girlfriend you know if you're just
messing around with someone get your
dick sucked if you can't find someone
pay a hooker get your dick so if it's
your [ __ ] birthday you gotta get your
dick sucked
buttery beans hey Ryan shut up please
I've asked before and if you give me one
the answer is yes I will butter your
beans or my beans supposed to meet my
balls
there you go like the butter off my
balls like a puppy
bars beans like cuz that could be make
you do something with another hole in
your body Boop I don't quite know I mean
maybe you're in something like that
[ __ ] kind of stuff food sex I don't
know a thing right you can have the
shoutout and I'm curious to find out
what it means to butter my beans so
buttery beans I challenge you to
actually butter my beans message me I'll
give you my address
I should just post my address on YouTube